l'épidémie de sida continue à progresser
en france 6700 personnes ont découvert
leur séropositivité l'an passé le
gouvernement lançait aujourd'hui une
nouvelle campagne de prévention avec
notamment le préservatif à 20 centimes
d'euro marie-pierre samitier mathias
baron j'ai flirté avec toi avec d'autres
et j'ai flirté avec le sida ce spot télé
comme ces préservatifs à 20 centimes
relance le combat contre le sida qui
continuent de progresser en france
d'où cette nouvelle campagne contre la
maladie dès vendredi 10 millions de
préservatifs seront vendus dans 23 1000
points de vente à 20 centimes l'unité on
retrouve le vieux principe du
préservatif à 1 franc avec du nouveau
c'est extrêmement nouveau c'était
interdit jusqu'à présent jusqu'à présent
on ne pouvait vendre un préservatif que
dans une boîte avec une notice on
pouvait pas le vendre au détail et ça ça
va vraiment tout changer car le sida 29
mille personnes en sont atteintes
et l'on estime qu'en france il ya cent
cinquante mille séropositifs dont six
mille 700 nouveaux cas l'an dernier la
moitié de ses 6700 cas ont été
contaminés par des rapports
hétérosexuels
les homosexuels représentent 27 % des
nouveaux séropositifs contre 73%
d'hétérosexuels parmi les six mille 700
nouveaux cas les victimes sont à 57 %
des femmes ela 48% des ressortissants
d'afrique sub saharienne
enfin l'accès au dépistage sera
facilitée notamment chez les médecins et
dans les hôpitaux